en un ambiente de falta de legitimidad y
desconfianza se celebran las elecciones
locales en Nicaragua y es que una serie
de irregularidades envuelven el proceso
de elección de esta jornada la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos había
hecho saber su preocupación por la
ausencia de condiciones
la cidh urge al Estado a restablecer las
garantías y libertades democráticas
propias de un estado democrático de
derecho mediante la separación de
poderes y el cese de la represión
varias son las denuncias que pesan sobre
el procedimiento el observatorio de
incidencia política urnas abiertas
reportó que el partido gobernante
utilizaba vehículos estatales para
trasladar votantes así como la
asistencia de uniformados armados dentro
de los centros de votación lo que
consideran una violación Aunque la ley
electoral de 2021 lo permite Mientras
estén cumpliendo sus funciones
habituales se conoció además que el
consejo supremo electoral dio de baja a
más de 700.000 electores así como la
aprobación de una ley por parte de la
nacional para votar incluso con la
cédula vencida según la vicepresidenta
de Nicaragua Rosario Murillo el proceso
electoral de este domingo consolida la
paz y la democracia es una lección que
garantiza nuestra dignidad nacional y
sobre todo nos une para fortalecer la
lucha contra la pobreza con las
principales voces disidentes
encarceladas al menos tres partidos
cuentan con una prohibición a su
participación de una población de más de
6 millones de personas fueron convocadas
a votar casi 4 millones